a good evening and welcome to Boris
Books and Music in westwood thanks for
coming out into the rain I'm rich Carter
I'm the community relations coordinator
here at borders westwood I'd like to
thank his ban about books for coming out
and recording this event Lou cannon is a
longtime political reporter in White
House correspondent for The Washington
Post he's also was the post los angeles
bureau chief from 77 280 and from 91 to
93 he's the author of five books
including three biographies of ronald
reagan tonight mr. cannon is here to
discuss his book official negligence how
Rodney King and the riots changed Los
Angeles in the LAPD critic mary carol
wrote cannons bad guys are neither King
nor the policeman jailed for violating
his civil rights either street cops
north street punks in general but Los
Angeles leaders who failed to lead and
avoid accountability please welcome Lou
cannon thanks rich I'm amazed and
anybody would come out in this weather
to hear anybody say anything thank you
Mary and Harlan for being here
particularly and thank you paula for
being such a wonderful escort I don't
really know what to say about this book
I spent five years writing it I thought
it in my take two and I just I'd covered
the the Rodney King case and the trials
and the riots for the Washington Post I
was dissatisfied with a lot of the
coverage I was dissatisfied with
some of the results I was horrified by
the riots which killed 54 people had
resulted in two thousand injuries and
nearly a million dollars of destruction
and eight hundred buildings lost a
bigger death toll in these riots than
any civil disorders since the draft
riots of the Civil of the Civil War a
lot of people have asked me when I I was
inspired to write this book I never was
really I just I had no experience like
Saul in the road to Damascus no
lightning struck but i do remember very
vividly when I picked the title for this
book and I was sitting in a in a during
one of the sentencing hearings I don't
know whether it was judge Davies sense
of humor or whether it was the fact that
there were a lot of people in the
courtroom or whether he just wanted to
give us a better view but those of us
who were in the press corps who were
there during the sentencing were seated
in the jurors chairs and I was in the
cherub particular juror who I
subsequently interviewed and an attorney
IRA Saltzman who quite candidly doesn't
come out all that well in this book
nonetheless had something in a
sentencing hearing sometimes people who
are not very eloquent who say things
that are eloquent resonate you know more
and this is what he said it was the city
that failed it was police management
past and present that has failed this
has to be taken into account to reflect
the just and fair sentence there simply
has to be some allowance for the
official negligence of the city which
allowed this to take place and will take
place again and I did come home after
that
say well that's that's the title of this
book we had to fight for this title with
the publisher but now they all think
it's a good title and I'm happy I'm
happy that they do this is a story this
is a lot of stories in one it's a story
that doesn't get told enough across the
country about Latasha Harlan's who was a
15 year old young woman an
african-american who walked into a
grocery store as convenience market
really in the worst part of south
central run by a Korean family the store
had been robbed an awful lot the woman
who was behind the counter a woman named
Sun jadoo was there because her husband
was exhausted and had worked around the
clock and and this was a Saturday
morning and she thought things would be
quiet and Latasha Harlan's went to the
refrigerating for the refrigerator in
the store the and took our orange juice
put it in her backpack walked out walked
up to the counter she had the money in
her hand to pay for it it's quite clear
that the sons I do didn't see that she
thought she was shoplifting she reached
for the orange juice which was and son
jett do was very small and frail and
Natasha Hines was large and she they
wrestled and Latasha Harlan's hit her
knocked her down hit her two or three
times whichever you however you
interpret this video tape because this
was on an in-store video tape people
didn't see it the police confiscated
afterwards anyway Latasha turned and as
she was walking away sunjai i do pull
this revolver out from below the counter
and shot her in the back of the head and
killed her and a mixed-race jury this
happened 13 days after Rodney King
incident a mixed-race jury found son's I
do guilty of voluntary manslaughter
which in California means that you
intended to kill but not with malice
and a white probation officer
recommended several years in prison and
the judge a novice judge who was judged
trying her first murder case because all
the senior judges in in her group had
ducked the case gave this game straight
probation to this person who killed a
teenager I've always thought of
latasha's the real victim of this
because the other people I write about
Rodney King and and the sergeant who
supervised the beating stacey koon my
respect but both of them are doing quite
well financially and latasha is dead
anyway I wrote about that case only
because every black person that I
interviewed said you got include that
it's part of the story I hadn't intended
to write about it and I wrote about the
King video tape because there were a lot
of things that happen in that videotape
that people don't know they think there
is this video tape where King is being
brutally beaten there are a lot of cases
in Los Angeles of street justice carried
out by by cops and some of them are
racial and some are not but they involve
cases often where somebody makes a a
wisecrack or slightly resistant and is
hit very hard by a police officer some
cases shot that wasn't what happened in
this case the what happened in this case
is the officers had tried for several
minutes before any video tape was made
to take Ronald Rodney King into custody
without hurting him he had thrown four
officers off his back he was sweating
profusely on a cold night he were only a
t-shirt a sergeant mccune then fired two
volleys of his son gun the Taser 50,000
volts each time I've seen what that can
do to people it puts them down for very
long
it didn't put Rodney King down for a
very long time he did he did feel the
effects of it he described it very
graphically to me but he got up the
videotape of the Rodney King beating
begins as rot as Rodney King gets up for
the second time and charges at officer
Lawrence Powell who struck most of the
blows in the incident the videotape
these opening three seconds of this
videotape shot by an amateur cameraman
across the street are a window into what
was not videotaped what you saw as the
videotape what most Americans saw is a
partial record of a parcel record
because after the first three seconds of
this videotape the amateur cameramen
George holiday who has moves his
camcorder slightly and he delivers 10
seconds of blurry footage when this tape
was taken into KTLA by the way mr.
holiday was a I think by any fair
description a good citizen you know he
was awakened in the middle of the night
by the police sirens and helicopter he
shot this video tape he he didn't really
know what he had but he knew it was
important and he called the foothill
police station and I and I will go to my
grave as will everybody else here
without ever knowing who answered him
because nobody in foothill has ever
acknowledged of answering that call they
said they weren't interested in the fact
and mr. Holliday took the videotape into
the channel in which he watched the
local news KTLA the first appearance
that I did on this book tour was by I
don't know it was it was either by
coincidence or by your doing Paul was it
KTLA and the
anchor asked me the question he said
some people have said we've done a
disservice by showing this videotape and
I said no you did a public service by
showing the videotape you did a
disservice by the way you edited it
because what they did in editing it and
presenting it on the news was they took
out these first 13 seconds the three
seconds in which you see the charge of
mr. King at mr. Powell and the next 10
seconds of blurry footage and so people
when they see this the videotape they
just see these officers whaling away at
Rodney King now this videotape as
sergeant Kuhn himself has said it in
testimony is brutal to look at in any
version it's a very brutal hard
videotape to look at but if you see the
first part of it it is not an
inexplicable videotape and what happens
what happens is that this editing which
is so unfair to the officers in its
originality becomes unfair really to the
prosecution after the cases moved to
Simi Valley I'm very critical of the
judiciary for doing that there was no
precedent for moving this case out of
Los Angeles these officers could have
been and should have been tried in Los
Angeles and the judge who moves it
ignores part of the appeal order which
says move it out of Los Angeles and move
it out of the media market he keeps it
in the media market the people in simi
valley watch the team's same television
stations in the same see that read the
same newspapers as you do but by moving
it there in this very Pro police
community it meant that the jury was
almost by definition not diverse there
were no black members of this jury now
these jurors were conservative they
believed that the media had not told him
the full story and we had and so when
the tape is played for the first time
the
in a tape these jurors if you were there
I was there their mouths are a game they
can't quite believe what they're seeing
but what's worse about this is it's
being played for them not by the defense
of the officers but the prosecution
under the well-worn trial theory that
you if you've got some evidence that
damaging to your side you want to put it
on before the other guys do the
prosecution never recovered from this it
played a big role in the subsequent
verdicts a lot of people have forgotten
that even in simi valley even with this
conservative jury that there were four
jurors who wanted to convict officer
Powell for assault under under color of
authority and the jury deadlocked on
that charge you'll often hear that they
were acquitted of all charges which
isn't which isn't true and I think in
some of my quicker stories in The
Washington Post I may have may have
fallen into the same error officer
Powell would have been tried again the
judge had already tried and decided to
try them again in Los Angeles when the
federal government took over the
prosecution this book is about the
official negligence of the judiciary
it's also about the official negligence
of the LAPD which ignored the warnings
ignored warnings from its own from its
own top officers the leadership did not
just Daryl gates but other members of
the leadership that a riot that these
officers could be acquitted and that a
riot could result today I was on which
way la on which way la in a previously
taped interview chief Barnard parks who
I'm an admirer of the present chief of
the LAPD was interviewed chief Park said
said that nobody anticipated these riots
before the riots here's a short memory
in a Sunday sermon given at the first
AME Church the most the oldest and most
politically active black church in Los
Angeles the
when Cecil Murray said he was worried he
said be cool he told the congregation
even an anger be cool and if you're
going to burn something down don't burn
down the house of the victim's brother
burn down the legislature burn down the
courtroom burn it down by voting brother
burn it down by standing with us at
Parker center brother burn it down by
saying dig Daryl gates as far and no
further but Murray had few illusions
that his impassioned plea for peace
would carry the day much is at stake for
our city and the longer the jury stays
out the more we tremble Murray told me
the day after his sermon the possibility
of the verdict being a flashpoint is
very high it was it was at least
official negligence some would say worse
for chief gates and Mayor Bradley to
ignore this kind of warning and it was
certainly official negligence the fact
that but that at gates and Bradley both
stiff-necked did not talk to each other
for 13 months before the riot when I say
this in eastern cities people don't
believe me but both of them do say this
and both of them blame the other I'm
gonna I I guess there's two other points
I want to make before I stopped because
this covers an awful lot of events and
it's a very long book it's a 300,000
word book and it and it has a lot of
different different viewpoints in it one
is that the LAPD ignored its own best
people in not preparing for a riot I
should say this that it also you know
nobody comes out of this completely
clean there were a lot of
african-american leaders who wanted not
Reverend Murray who wanted the LAPD to
stay out of South Central and said so
because they thought they might provoke
a ride and then accuse them of
abandoning South Central after the riot
but here in this little brief thing that
I'm going to read to you Mike Hillman
who was then the head of Metro the
LAPD's elite division was telling LAPD
leaders that they'd better prepare for a
riot the doctrine of the LAPD was that
after wats that you the wats ride of
1965 at you crush a riot immediately by
by a massive force gates and other
senior officials and crucial decision
making positions during the Simi Valley
trial believed that any potential
disturbances would likely follow the
pattern of watts we're rioting had
flared by day and subsided had flared by
night and subsided during the day when
lieutenant Michael Hillman asked
permission a week before the 1992 riots
to deploy the department's elite Metro
unit during daytime hours he was told by
this particular deputy chief riots don't
happen during the daytime even though it
was obvious the jury wasn't going to
come back in the middle of the night I
described the ride in different ways I
described it as an original cry of black
rage it became a lot of other things I
try to use the word plural to describe
the riots when they went on for five
days there was a lot of looting
eventually there were more Latino
participants than there were black
participants but in its originality at
the epicenter at Florence in Normandy
where the riot could have been stopped
all of the all of the assailants were
african-americans people know that from
watching the video tape of the Denny BTW
what they don't know and which is also
distorted in effect by this video by the
coverage is that all of the people who
were rescued at florence and normandy
and nobody lost their life they're all
over fifty four people killed in the
riots were rescued by african-americans
a few by african-american and police
officers most by African American
civilians like the three men and one
woman who watched the Denny beating on
video tape as hard as it is to imagine
as hard as it is to imagine most of the
police officers didn't know about this
at the time there was no television in
the command center where they were a
little more than a mile away and these
people at great risk to themselves went
down to the intersection
one of them Bobby green had a license to
drive an 18-wheeler truck he drove this
truck with Denny decide while these
other three people went to the hospital
Denny had a seizure just before they
reached the hospital and and green
thought that he was he was dead but it
turned out he was clinging to life and
the doctor said that if he'd got their
little or a few minutes later that he
would have been dead two of the doctors
were african-americans two people didn't
see this and the other thing I guess the
only other thing I'd mentioned I'd be
happy to take your questions and as far
as I'm able to answer them is that the
first trial was widely criticized
because of its result the second trial
was widely praised because of its result
but the second trial was also not held
in a level playing field the second
trial was held in los angeles it was a
federal trial in which the officers were
charged with violating king civil rights
President Bush had in effect given
marching orders for this trial when he
said in the middle of the riots he had
some reason for saying it there were
demonstrations in 20-some cities across
America that this isn't over so that
officers the officers were prosecuted
and the juror and it was held in
downtown Los Angeles and there was no
change of venue asked for by the defense
and the officers were tried there and
every night the foreman of the jury
according to his own statement would
would go up and look from the window of
the high floor in the Hilton Hotel where
they were saying and look out and say
South Central isn't burning yet and then
tell us the jurors there was a terrible
bomb scare that frightened these jurors
during the middle of it what I'm saying
is these just as as the first trial was
scored by the fact there were no blacks
on the jury the second trial was was
effected for the fact that people
believe that if they didn't return
convictions there might be another riots
there are maybe no level playing fields
anywhere on this
are jurors are concerned there certainly
were none in either of these trials I
don't blame the jurors for that I I
think too much blame has been heaped on
the jurors I try to put it on on the
officials people who are elected people
are pointed people who are judges for
life finally I would say that with a few
exceptions there are there aren't a lot
of heroes in my book but the heroes that
are there are ordinary people they're
ordinary civilians in south-central who
opposed the burning of buildings and who
save the victims and their ordinary
rank-and-file cops I tell at one
particular harrowing rescue by two by
two officers one male and the other
female who in a sense defied their own
leadership and went out and and rescued
people who were in danger so I guess in
my book the counterpart to the official
negligence is the heroism of ordinary
people most of whom are not known today
by name I'll rest on that see there was
a young
before the three-second there was there
was a lot of action in a five or six
minutes yes that's before the three
seconds that's before the videotape
began the importance to me of those
three seconds one of the defense
attorneys I believe it was the Paul
DiPasquale the defense attorney for
officer win who was acquitted twice he
was acquitted in Simi Valley he was
acquitted in the federal trial he was
found not liable for Kings injuries the
latter two by juries of mixed race I
think it's fair to say that officer win
would have been acquitted in any
jurisdiction anywhere at any time his
attorney said that thank God for the
video which is not what you'd think that
an attorney for the defense would say
because if it started a little later a
few seconds later nobody would have
believed that they would have thought we
were just making it up that Rodney King
charged it officer Powell the fact is
the importance of those three seconds to
me at least is that they are a window
onto the larger incident that was never
recorded and and and I believe very
strongly that ktla had an obligation and
the the other television stations took
by the way took this edited video not
knowing it was edited and not inquiring
about it with the sole and distinguished
exception of the director of CNN news at
the time head turner and they never
found out it was edited they just ran it
as it was yes sir I can't I have a hard
time looking the light like everybody
else yes
look no sir with Charlie Rose yet that's
one question well I can't do anything
with book notes because my friend Brian
lamb who had me on twice on the Reagan
PO I share the dubious distinction of
being the only person other than Richard
M Nixon who was on two episodes of book
notes because he gave he gave my last
book President Reagan the role of a
lifetime to eps and he only does one
author one time a lot of people don't
like that I have a lot of friends who
are good authors who written good books
you know never been on booked outs
that's fine with me I know I haven't
done charlie rose I've done charlie rose
a lot of on other books and i've
appeared in Charlie Rose's programs in
the middle of the night when he was with
CBS and I'd be happy to Charlie if he
wants me the question I had was you said
you admired since desi crew well yeah I
spent out a life of covering people
politicians usually but also cops and
other people and most people you know
never take the blame it's always
somebody else's fault I mean the worst I
mean and then in the in the in the Nazi
case it was in followed orders but but
in our society it's always you know the
devil made me do it or Joe is
responsible or you know or Nancy didn't
get there in time or Stacey takes
responsibility for every blow in that
incident I disagree with him he thinks
this was a management control use of
force the prosecution thinks it's a
criminal act I conclude it was a bungled
and arrest you know but but i don't i
don't agree with with Stacey's views of
this arrest but he takes responsibility
for every blow that was struck including
blows he never saw I don't know of any
case I've ever covered any trial i've
ever covered I don't know of any
politician I've ever covered who said I
blew the election you know it's always
somebody else's fault yeah and in our
society it's always somebody else's
fault I at least the least this guy
takes
possibility for actions stubbornly i
think you know i don't i don't share his
view of the case but I do admire that
sure
thank you very much for for coming out
on such a night lieutenant mr. cannon
will be signing for us will be lining up
over here we'll be setting up a table if
you like a book signed thank you all for
coming
why let this Borders Books and Music in
Los Angeles Lou cannon signed copies of
his new book official negligence how
Rodney King and the riots changed Los
Angeles and the LAPD here's a look I
always always hoped the bathrooms you do
so are your six book you don't like you
try not to be jobs to hire your peers
too low you know you I'll give you a
call tomorrow i should be back is that
ok is that too sentimental very nice not
even really not if not well you you
think we have access to a lot of copies
of this yeah yeah you read that and
always okay
wait if it's not okay wrong besides huh